good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast our final episode of the
week before Jackie and I hit the road
head to Poconos PA for camp toast
weekend 2019 I mean that's really weird
because we're not just going alone and
let's have someone here who's coming
with us that campers don't know this yet
but someone tell American Italian and
French camper that Theodore the Chairman
is coming to campus it was a last-minute
decision I just really felt like I
didn't want to leave him and to go to a
campground it's like so much free room
to run and grass and not take my boy
would be criminal
it would have been selfish and it was
gonna be so many campers there that like
you know can keep an eye on him if he
goes running wild but you know what he
should like he's at dogs are descendants
of wolves and he very much has earned
this vacation like he's the
hardest-working doctor on the eastern
seaboard and I feel as if he deserves to
be rewarded is it the eastern seaboard
or the eastern seaboard you know I
really intentionally like left out the
last word the last letter cuz you didn't
know they don't know I want to say Borg
uh really I would think it's the
seaboard I'm pretty sure it's the Borg
speaking of do you see Ramona on watch
shop inside last night saying that
Charleston was the west coast
no that's hilarious is and he was like
Ramona but she was on with Craig
she was ed would you ever set up Avery
with Craig she goes no I he lives on the
west coast I know everyone was like dead
silent and and he was like Charles
students not on the west coast that's so
funny that's a really good match I know
I ship it
me too my ship is coming in okay well we
got bay of salt but my ship is coming it
will recap rioni and southern charm yes
then we also have Leila or from Project
Runway on the show today and Jerry Bravo
jet that's pretty cool and all but she's
also a toaster which is even cooler yeah
no totally I just like I have so many
questions for her like what's it like to
be a toaster and go on a show like
knowing when you're done like you'll
probably come on the toast like epic do
you think about how we're gonna talk
about you that's such a great another
element like another layer of just being
a reality star that was like when we
were at Coachella and we met that
girlfriend big brother yes was a major
toaster and she was just using her
platform to spread toasty buns which is
all you can ask for talking about the
toast and like using
see lingo while she was like being
recorded 24/7 that's all you can post
there sniffed her out every true toaster
knows of their mission in this life is
to go forth and spread toasty vibes like
when you're on a platform as big as the
Big Brother if you're not spreading
toasty vibes you are not a true toaster
right exactly but the true toast service
will be at kam toast this weekend I'm so
excited finally we figured out what to
pack for the scam honestly I don't think
we did because I just throw a bunch of
[ __ ] in a car and we're hitting the road
I'm wearing workout clothes and merch
all weekend the merch is truly what's
going to clothe this thick body yes and
Thea will get his merch and yeah it's
it's not even about like what you look
like it's about how you feel it's so
true like I don't even know if I'm gonna
be going into this with makeup like I'll
see how I feel but like I'm just here to
really dive deep into the toastie vibes
and I'm really looking forward to it
me too but we can't go ahead to camp
without delivering the fast I story is
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast I can't believe it's already camp
toast weekend again it's the craziest
thing you guys life is flying my it
really is and so I feel about like
watching Theo grow up in what's crazy is
like sometimes you feel like wow life is
going faster than ever but it's it's
going at the same speed as it was going
when you were sitting in class like
watching the clock move no that's what
he said Lee was but it wasn't no and
like some time this show goes the same
speed of an hour workout like that's not
that's not possible
you know yeah you were giving me like a
lot of Scarlett Johansson in match-point
vibes today oh thank you I definitely
went with a tennis theme because I just
thought this little tennis skirt and
like I had to wear it all the way and I
was just like feeling campy and it's a
moral a weekend like we can start
wearing white I just wanted to embrace
that well then I got this sweatshirt off
of Amazon Oh off of your new favorite
blogger oh my god
shocking her stories because you were
speaking so highly and then I wound up
finding this sweater that is so funny
um wait also one more thing I wanted to
say oh my outfit yesterday and today I'm
really inspired by the car that we got
for our road trip we got a I want to say
it's a Lexus I'm calling it the mom car
but it's I think it's a Lexus G whatever
thanks Riley Lexus for the hook-up
and it's very like you know Hamptons mom
of three and yesterday I was just
walking around in my loaf
like with this Lexus like I really felt
like the person like I've always wanted
to be and so now I'm just like driving
around town in this car really feeling
like empowered to be this like it's not
a like you know waspy kind of woman and
this sweater just gives me that kind of
vibe
totally you're a Hamptons mom and I'm
your kid yeah they are taking me and
dropping you up at sport tennis practice
totally I really need to work on my game
I've been really disappointing no I know
and like you're gonna embarrass me at
the Country Club Heather really I'm
sorry mom mom this is not my dream it's
yours no you're like American campers
mom yeah I'm American and I'm like
training I'm like working you to the
bone until you come and tell me like
being a tennis player it's just it was
like my failed dream not yours and but
that's what makes sense by American
camera when she gets to camp she has
like so much and that's why she lets
have to counter snitch so much because
her mom like really doesn't give her
that loving nurturing feeling the plot
thickens the plot thickens
and like the American cameras backstory
like she puts on a brave face but she's
been through a lot you know Wells has
been through a lot Ramona oh my god I
just I found that at this episode to be
astonishing and quite educational um yes
and it was the most interesting
television I've watched in a while and I
genuinely like wanted more of it like
you would think would we want to watch
like the kitchen cabaret funny drama and
goodbye you have been flirting with guys
were like no Ramona in a restaurant
where she held her mother's funeral
lunch talking about her childhood with
Bethenny like I just I felt like it was
just such so important well good to
understand what that's third there do
here are the stories that you need to
know and you know we're always honest
about how how much you need to know them
today is like a medium okay well that's
good could be a lot of other stuff to do
okay but first up apparently
kendall Jenner and Ben Simmons have
broken up oh I heard about that
apparently the relationship was quote
run its course apparently they were
actually together
kendall Jenner an NBA star Ben Simmons
have split when you break up with
someone of you were never really
together I don't know me neither
I do not know sources said that at the
same time in new Australia Vogue cover
story dropped quoting supermodels
Kendall saying of potentially marrying
Simmons quote maybe definitely not now
but maybe one day Simmons was partying
solo in Atlantic City in New Jersey with
power
Simmons Chad Simmons was spotted with
friends at Kuro at the Hard Rock Hotel
and casino's celebrating a friend's
birthday we hear that the group later
turned up at scores and that there was
buzz among Ben's entourage that he and
Jenner called it quits last week another
source familiar with the couple said
that they have broken up there's no love
lost here for me because anytime Kendall
Jenner's in one of her Christian
orchestrated their relationships I just
know that like the contract ended you
know yeah the term is up yeah like
Kendall Jenner's boyfriend's in the past
have served a variety of purpose I think
this one was just like to keep her
relevant just like all of her sisters
are like moving forward I'm like doing
so many things I'm like I genuinely
forgot that Kendall exists so like Kris
was like girl you gotta go together get
a boyfriend [ __ ] Ben not Ben Simmons was
like the Kris Humphries of hello
Jenner's lifetime I do think though that
her brief stint on a yacht with Harry
Styles was maybe a real one but other
than that juicy Harry Styles was started
out with kaya Gerber yes on the beach
like playing cornhole
it was branded custom egos and she was
probably like dad I think it was like a
class like because it's Brandon Cosme
because I think it was a party like I
think I don't know that they elected to
hang out no not at all but you know what
when I saw the pictures I thought kayo
is Kendall it's so crazy they look
exactly like it really Harry has a type
Oh totally
it's so it's a you know great for me
that Harry's type just happens to be
like my physique you know like really
tall fit brunette and like just gorgeous
too bad I married Harry too bad you're
not into him um so Kendall and Ben
Simmons okay it's just uh ya know time's
up but I just I don't know like I never
I didn't care when they were together I
don't care that they're apart you know
do I think this was you know the
greatest love story this town has ever
seen no no neither do I do you know how
hard it was for me not to sing that oh
you could sing it no it's okay they've
broken me I thought I saw an interesting
factoid like obviously Kendall was ain't
can for that fell Harley because you
know she's a big actress the biggest
which is just something that we've
spoken about before I'm not in the mood
to like delve into why are certain
people that can you know yeah um but she
was not Kylie skin and then someone said
maybe it's because like she can't
promote another skincare line oh my god
is a pre-contract with Proactiv a
thousand percent also I want to talk
about can for one second you did see
this video that's going viral of margot
robbie quentin tarantino at the press
conference
now okay so they're they're promoting
their Sharon time time in Hollywood and
it's it's the the Q&A with the press and
the the crew and it's Quentin Tarantino
Margot Robbie Leonardo DiCaprio I'm Brad
Pitt like all in the frame and a
reporter asks like Quentin like you have
this world renowned actress like maybe
the best actress of our time right now
she was so amazing with Leo and wolf of
wallstreet she lists her accolades but
for the first hour of the movie you give
her no lines kind of insinuating you
know Quentin Tarantino I was like this
controversial figure it was basically
insinuating like you wouldn't let the
woman talk that's what I got okay
and she asked Quentin and then she also
has Margo both to answer and Quentin
goes like he's like I reject your
hypothesis I didn't say anything else
I'm like Margot Robbie jumped in and
whether or not margot robbie feels as if
she wasn't given enough lines she
certainly wasn't gonna like you know
disk which in tight you know and that
he's feeding shoes she came up with the
most brilliant line she was like i you
know i really liked that because i'm
used to developing a character based on
their conversations with other people
but spending so much time alone in this
character really was a challenge for me
and one that i accepted a lot just to
really you know build the character from
within and i was like damn she pulled
that sure right out of her ass totally
that is a line of horseshit yeah but
that's very interesting but then i went
down this rabbit hole of like
controversial quentin tarantino isms and
i'm not gonna lie i'm not educated at
all but and i have to say that now but
the insinuation was that like he's this
misogynist who like didn't want to let
the woman talk but then there's like all
this these people were like coming in
its defense like that he is known for
developing female roles like really like
powerful empowering female roles like
Kill Bill yeah so I was just thinking
yeah I there definitely is some stuff
wrong with Quentin Tarantino but I don't
know if the woman thing was one of them
okay I'll look into it yeah thanks for
the interesting factoid Quentin
Tarantino such an odd figure because I
know there's a lot about him that's like
batting controversial but anyone who
could come up with the Inglourious that
was a glorious bastard it's like he's a
genius you know yeah I mean totally
imagine if we just got to burn the Nazis
alive before they were able to do
anything yeah and like we couldn't but
at least we can watch a movie about it
oh my god
goodbye Shoshana do you know that story
no what's that line in or revoir
shosanna
okay in the very beginning of
inglourious basterds Shoshana who ends
up being the woman who wants a theater
she escaped the Nazis and the Nazi like
sees her running out of the house and he
can't get to her so he just yells he's
like au revoir shosanna Christoph Waltz
like in the most Nazi voice ever how
does he know her name because they knew
all the Jews they were coming to find
like the Jews they literally had a list
of all the Jews and they were coming to
kill and he killed her whole family and
she got away and she's running away and
Christoph Waltz is like goodbye No au
revoir shosanna and me and been like two
years ago were at like this function
with one of our friends when a new
boyfriend and they're no longer together
and I'm not gonna slander the name but
she was with this this new boyfriend and
we were saying bye to them on the street
they were going one way we were going
the other so me and then start walking
away more like bye and the girls new
boyfriend he goes
au revoir shosanna I'm you know get each
other and we're like um it's not like
what the Nazis had I'm like that was
just like a weird way to say goodbye to
someone you just met Jerry yes that's
what I think I wanted to think of
glorious bastards Oh got it
funny great movie thanks Ari
from the Kendall generator to the world
World War two it always ends up back at
World War two are you ready for the next
story
a little Bravo news because Lisa
Vanderpump has apologized for her
transphobic joke okay aimed at Erika
Girardi it was my quote this is her
statement it was not my intention to
belittle the trans community with my
poor choice of words directly towards
Erika Vanderpump told page six in a
statement on Wednesday I have nothing
but respect and love for trans people
around the world as I have been a
staunch supporter provided employment
offered emotional support and championed
Albi LGBTQ issues with recent news of
trans women losing their lives for their
authentic truth in a world of
discrimination and hate I never want to
diminish the very real pain and struggle
that trans people go through every day
yeah I mean we don't we didn't think she
was transphobic but it's indicative of
this attitude that she has like thinking
she's just above the law yeah and that
like she is just so mean to people that
like most people when you say something
like you think about how that might come
off right especially her she's been on
TV for so long like she
has not made a mistake like this ever
but it was like her blind hatred of
these women allowed her to say something
that she couldn't even consider might be
offensive because she couldn't see
anything other than her own point yeah
being an ally of the LGBTQ community
does not give you a path to say whatever
you want for sure but I think you know
her actions like you know what's this
what's a what's the phrase
speak louder than actions speak louder
than words like her words that were you
know not great but her actions have been
wonderful and I think that's what's most
important here and you know what I'm the
first to stomp on lb P's grade but this
is not where I want to hang my hat up
because it's unfair no I agree
I totally it's like but I do love like
everyone coming for it's like when Billy
Lee was calling katie transphobic
because of a poster like no stretch
stretch reach city she's carried out on
a stretcher reach city reach reach City
[ __ ] exactly that song that was like
the pop pop enjoy gasps oh my god yeah
that was my first introverted a [ __ ]
rug rug through the baby she's also on
that song um with Neon Hitch gold it's
like there yes keep going oh I'm feeling
the beat in my shoulder you shall not go
oh what a sheen heavy day everything
also comes back to the Kardashians
always I mean we already knew that and
you know what I'm glad I did because
they wanted to talk about something I
didn't want to include in the Fast Five
because it's old news but it came out on
a Friday and we never had a chance to
talk about the name Sam West oh we get
okay it's that how you pronounce it I'm
like some PSA LM is never a word we had
to use growing up because it's not a
part of our religion it's just a word
I've definitely seen written places but
never really spoke and I don't
understand how to pronounce it there's
no page silent some know it's like bomb
that is such a hard I think I think
please correct me if I'm wrong so cuz
I'm uneducated I'm you know what it's
beautifully written like when I saw a
Psalm West like written on her Instagram
I was like damn that's beautiful but now
I'm out here saying Psalm West and it
doesn't just you know roll off the
tongue no it says
but I think if you grew up saying it all
the time you wouldn't think it was a
hard word to say and then maybe it does
roll off the tongue and what do you
nickname some like you would think maybe
P but they have a comma P saw me
Salmonella Salmonella I love that I like
that too it's a little long for a
nickname oh yeah you're fine
beautiful SEO and we found a way to call
you w door for chairman's yeah he went
from two syllables to three such em on
the Chapman he's just so [ __ ]
precious for it it's pretty I you know
it's very in theme with what they're
going through right now you know really
having the spiritual awakening so I love
that they want something religious you
can never go wrong with a biblical name
that's not the really biblical name I
was thinking but still no I love it I
you can't go wrong with a biblical name
I personally like I wonder if they even
thought of free I just wanted like yeah
I wanted to get their take on it that
would be like a Jewish person naming it
like puss ik yeah yeah which is pretty
ish not that word puss suck oh my god we
need the fee okay I'm right now he's
being so [ __ ] cute just like laying
at our feet it's just crazy when you're
doing you're working and an angel shows
up yeah and it's so hard to like be
present when you're literally in the
presence of magic of a sound and it's
probably frustrating for the podcast
listeners but honestly I encourage you
to watch today's live stream because
there's so much goddamn cute and it's
just oozing out of the show go over to
the 17 minute mark of the video because
there's a precious gem of them between
my sweater
jockeys outfit and like those presents I
mean the cuteness just can't be tamed no
much like Miley Cyrus it can't beat a
team and it shan't be tamed
I shan't be attained I should detained I
won't be teased
[Laughter]
okay next story and when we haven't
spoken about in a while but I'm
concerned he depend tears boyfriend
Bryan Hickerson has been charged with
felony domestic violence the independent
tears boyfriend could face jail time
following his arrest earlier this month
the LA County District Attorney's Office
has charged Bryan Hickerson with one
count of felony domestic violence
TMZ reported if convicted he faces up to
four years in prison
LAPD arrested Hickerson following an
incident on his home with pennant iere
the former national star and Hager
and we're drinking in Hollywood before
allegedly getting into a physical
altercation at home it is unclear who
called the cops but after police
interviewed the couple they took
Hickerson into custody on felony
domestic violence charges for allegedly
starting the fight please reportedly
noticed redness and marks on Penna dears
body as well I have like a very special
place in my heart for Hayden Panettiere
know it might be like the bring it on to
of it all or I don't know there's just
something about her spunky vibe her
petite vibe that I've always been really
drawn to yeah and I also feel like she's
one of those she's like a Bethenny like
she I'm constantly reading bad news
about her like she just can't catch a
break I know she went through like
really hard postpartum depression after
her first kid and she's just had like a
lot of relationship troubles and then
Nashville about canceled like I just
really feel for her I feel her too and I
think she also had a very troubled
upbringing which has contributed to a
lot of the issues she was a oh my god
raising Helen she was a child actress
that's why I love her right
and Nashville Juliette Barnes and it was
crazy that it's crazy now how much like
life imitated art on that show for her
like she went to get treatment for
postpartum depression at the same time
that her character did maybe that was on
purpose but like so they could be a mom
I mean it it all worked out hopefully I
mean I just like I want to protect her
at all costs and I feel as though she's
not being productive I know and you know
with something like this this story kind
of reminds me that's a little different
of like the when Amanda and Bobbie you
like got arrested for whatever it's like
sometimes you get drunk and like you
yell at your boyfriend they're like
that's not a does not a domestic
violence situation make she had marks on
her so this is like a little bit more
suspicious no I think they're that like
they're there's more to this story
oh you think I don't think it's in a
minute not me situation where it's like
she's 90 pounds and like flailing her
arms
yeah and hotel security comes upstairs
yeah like this is please this is marks
on body look how much bigger he is than
her and he's the one who got arrested
not her she also reminds me a little bit
of Hilary Duff in the sense that they
look similar and they're always dating
people that I've never heard of yeah and
it's like not going well right and like
their stars are so high like they should
be dating someone of equal caliber
success yeah well for our while hayden
Panettiere was dating that guy like that
really big guy do you remember him no
maybe it's um I don't want to get the
name wrong
he didn't Panettiere hardest like a name
to spell boyfriend I think her
ex-boyfriends last name was even crazier
okay who she's
needed on ranker brian Hankerson
obviously he's not tired o
wladimir klitschko oh yes um and i think
he was a fighter he's in heavyweight
champion oh no I mean I just like love
her so much she is so precious and I
agree she's someone who's failing at
their job because she's not being
protected at all costs
Stephen Colletti she seduced Stephen
Colletti wait a minute 2006 we passed
that I thought it was Pete Davidson
efforts and I was like oh my god what
Evan Ross oh my god she's to date Evan
Ross Ashlee Simpson well he really took
a stumbling down what a great roster
meal oh then Timmy glia from what this
is us yeah they dated for a long 2008 to
2009 okay now as long she dated to see
Jessie wow she's really like cementing
her icon status in my mind no totally
and it's like she dated all these guys
like before they got pretty big so maybe
she's like a good luck Chuck Fame wise
oh she also needed a football player
named Scotty McKnight who was drafted by
the New York Jets that was literally a
storyline for Juliette Barnes when she
dates a football player and first Oh
life is imitating and she's literally
it's like it's a Kris Humphries
relationship and he's like she just
wants to be married or just imitating he
was like a Tim Tebow it would like him
and she lost her mind anyways what a
trip down memory lane
anyways Juliet oh well we're thinking of
you Hayden yeah here I forget her name
is Hayden Panettiere it's not hidden
Hayden like is any weird to think that
her first name is your husband's middle
name it's so I was just thinking that
they're two they're two totally
different Ames like no but annually
Hayden Weinreb is not the same as Hayden
Panettiere no but he was named after her
how beautiful psyche to see know my
Jack's mom is a big racing Helen fan
actually I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say raising Helen is in my top 10
favorite movies really yeah it's such a
good movie and it doesn't get spoken
about enough oh and the best part
Lynette Scavo was in it true and oh my
god the mom from ice princess Joan
Cusack a great cast and a great Hudson
right
yeah she's raising Helen yeah um and
hayden Panettiere oh and I'm Gayle
Breslin Wow it's really a star so it and
John Cusack yeah we know not junkie so
Jeff Corbett John Corbett Eamonn yeah I
got good news because Joan Cusack our
children John brother and sister perhaps
John Corbett is the pastor and he's like
it's he's the Lutheran pastor he's like
yeah I'm just gonna need to do blood
tests to make sure you know all the kids
are actually Lutheran
oh man it's such a good movie she learns
like yes that's definitely trust movie
of the week material but do we just say
oh no I had a thought that the movie
with a Hailee Steinfeld sophie Turner
and Doug Cameron
it's called barely lethal week okay we
will figure it out it's a winner yeah
well we'll get back to that okay
next story little biz fashion news and
know we love the fast song I mean look
at me I'm literally the height of all
things fashion fashion what is the
fashion is I probably already know about
it just because I'm so like I'm so
fashionable I'm so the definition of
like oh Cuccia that it's like it's
scaring me like I might not know this
information
Prada I mean my [ __ ] sweater was like
sixty [ __ ] dollars in my jeans we're
like 80 my sweater was like sixteen
dollars Wow
yeah my shoes although actually I'm
sorry my sweater was zero dollars free
yeah I'll tell you why later okay
actually here I'll show you I mean I
don't know how you've gone this long
without hearing the fashion is oh my god
I'm still wearing the tag I gotta get
this all right it's not killing you to
know the fashion news I mean I probably
already know it's oh no okay
Prada has banned fur as fashion mouse
again to ethical concerns oh of course I
already knew this and as a fashionista
you know to my bones but also a true
animal rights activist I couldn't be
more thrilled one of the fashion
industry's most iconic designers is
turning her back on fur Miuccia Prada
the creative director and controlling
shareholder of Milan based Prada Spa
said in a statement her company also the
maker of mule and church's shoes would
no longer feature the materials starting
September with her next runway show the
brand joins the ranks I'm sorry the
brand joins the ranks of labels like
Burberry group carrying essays Gucci
Armani Versace and Chanel and giving up
the materials use bowing to decades-long
criticism from animal rights and
environmental groups as consumers become
increasingly [ __ ] cerned about the
social and environmental impacts of
fashion banning fur has become a way for
brands to show they're serious about
curbing the industry's most harmful
excess I mean I just think this is so
great I'm so thrilled
kudos to Prada you're a little late but
you know it's better late than never and
I'm just I'm thrilled I know I think
that they're there they're coming in at
a good time I didn't realize that Chanel
and Gucci maybe there didn't use first
so I guess that's the good news it's
like I didn't even notice so I don't
think it should make much of a
difference yeah also technically like
faux fur prices should be a little
easier on the wallet yes my I'm just
here for this all around because I don't
have skin in this game no literally I
think for certain things like Canada
goose and they're like four you know if
you're like in the cold Tundras of the
world sometimes you need fur but we are
not so no you don't need fur from a
[ __ ] Canada goose like it's literally
the trim that little fur is decorative
it doesn't even keep you always what
stuff inside the jacket is okay so yeah
I have a [ __ ] like cheap-ass feather
comforter from Target like you can
figure it out if you want to keep warm
put bricks inside okay no I mean this
this story directly affects me I have so
many like thousand dollar products is in
my closet that I've just been deciding
not to wear in protest against the the
inhumanity of wearing fur but now that
Pradas decided I can finally take out on
my couch or items or just wear them all
around camp looking camp yeah that's
exciting for you I know you were like so
torn up about it with all the product or
closet you know I mean I would I would
dare to say I'm proud of like number one
customer you know and it's been really
hard for me so now this news has
affected me in such a positive way that
all my Torchic HR items are just ready
to go and of course back to the Theodore
for ten minutes just over the moon about
it you know him and his fur friends
finally get to live in peace yeah like
probably some rotten from the product
poachers from product to nada
finally some [ __ ] oh you know with
Pratt from Prada to nada is a movie okay
ready you're gonna Jack in this story
it's a movie with Alexa Vega and Camilla
Belle now it's about like two girls who
go from Prada janata from rich to poor
and it was on once like on like when I
was watching TV in high school like
before
bed on Cinemax and I put it on and I'm
like this looks different and it was a
porno called from Prada to not I guess
cuz like she took her father's shirt off
and there was it was brilliant but it
was really it got me I was like was it
remember this Couture porn he was a
chichi I was very elevated porno choo
choo that's like the poor Anna Wintour
watch yeah it might have been like from
nada to nada
like I might have just like skipped it I
mean I might have just like glazed over
and assumed or it was from products not
I don't remember I was just like excited
to see Alexa Vega on my screen and Yancy
and Camilla Belle in like her last role
ever ever what did ya did she pay her
bills I don't know man ask this and
final story in news that's affecting New
Yorkers and Olivia Ashura everywhere let
me guess what this is about if it's
about Olivia some of you had an office
no okay
give it one more guess you could get it
Starbucks yes okay Starbucks accused of
exposing New York City customers to
toxic pesticide to lawsuits filed
against Starbucks claimed that several
New York City stores expose customers to
a poisonous and potential deadly
pesticide toxin and then fired a store
manager who complained about them in one
class action suit filed on Tuesday in
state court in Manhattan 10 Starbucks
customers claimed they were quote
exposed to a toxic chemical declaw
boasts or DeeDee VP after making
purchases in multiple City stores over
the last three years
DeeDee VP is an ingredient that is
emitted into the air by a pesticide
called hot shot no pest strips which are
produced by spectrum brand Holdings the
lawsuit states that Starbucks uses the
strips in its Manhattan stores to keep
cockroaches and other pests away the
strips which can be purchased in many
home and garden stores as well as online
kill insects but are also harmful to
human beings according to the lawsuit
spectrum brand Holdings did not
immediately return NBC News's requests
for comment I mean I would rather have
like a little toxicity in my coffee then
have my coffee be made next to
cockroaches okay but like the toxicity
is deadly so we'd rather be dead or have
your coffee made next to cockroaches or
just go somewhere else for your coffee
because this is right and the worst
thing about Starbucks you know totally I
mean I was just in Israel and Israel
doesn't have any Starbucks they have the
Starbucks of Israel which is aroma and
it's so much [ __ ] better like I
literally have never in my life woken up
in the morning and been like I need a
coffee I don't drink coffee I've no
cravings for Starbucks and they're
Devils brew
but when I was in Israel every morning I
was like take me to my nearest aroma the
most delicious crunchy ice coffee of all
time so just knowing that this [ __ ]
tiny little third-world country can do
better than Starbucks makes me realize
that Starbucks you [ __ ] don't stink I
know sorry yes yes it's the devil's brew
and this Danish especially in New York
New Yorkers there's no reason for you to
be going to Starbucks
we have premium artisanal coffee shops
on every single corner also get a Keurig
yeah
Jackie's all about her Keurig I don't
drink coffee and you know what I was
thinking about the other day that story
that made you laugh like a year ago
someone came over to my house to do my
hair and my favorite story and the more
I tell it the less funny again no I know
but um I just think it's like so
pertinent again Rosie's graces so I the
way it was now three years ago cuz you
were are meeting you were being a
homemaker in your old apartment and I
was just like my fridge was like full of
like water and someone came over I'm
like do you want anything like water
like somebody's eyes have a straight way
you originally called it was good I
remember we just moved into your new
apartment and it was it was a very
swanky place and you were really taking
pride in being a homemaker and you
wanted to be the house that has
everything you need a charger she's got
it you want a soda
she's got it water Snapple tea I
wouldn't my home to be the place where
everyone wanted to be and they didn't
like to leave that like it just had
everything so she had some people come
over you were doing a shoot I think for
some like snapchat TV yes and you went
into a home maker mode can I offer you
something a water a teeny etc and the
person was like yeah can I have a coffee
this is a weird thing to order in
someone's house like what do you think I
have like a pot on I was just so odd and
I was like so floored because I was
ready to be this a Suze like homemaker
and he asked for the one thing I didn't
have and I'm like I don't have a coffee
machine like I literally think I'm like
how the [ __ ] can I make coffee right now
like I mean it's just like this isn't
cafe okay like you bring your own coffee
in you ask for water cook like
technically like it was it's not a crazy
request it just was so beyond your scope
right like I've never if some I will you
of akyurek so if someone asked you for a
coffee like you could make one huh
that's interesting it was interesting it
was just like a weird moment for me was
like we were thought you thought you
were ready it's like I had thought of
everything except like
was obvious thing yeah I don't know why
I just cracked me up man I mean now I
just have my daily harvest so anytime
anyone comes over I'm like would you
like a smoothie smoothie a whole green
Bowl I need some energy like are you
feeling low I'll give you a protein bowl
yes why why yes I am this time you come
over I'll pop it in on this on the
blender and we'll get it going because
when was the last time you made a
breakfast that you felt good about not a
bowl of sugary cereal you inhaled before
running out the door I'm talking about a
breakfast that's nourishing your body my
breakfast had been completely
transformed ever since I started getting
to Le harvest it's ready in five minutes
Max and I have a real organic fruit and
vegetable before I even finished my
morning coffee or in my case morning
diet coke jelly harvest delivers
carefully sourced chef's crafted
smoothies savory bowls overnight oats
and more built on fruits and vegetables
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to eat it you could
choose for more than 50 nourishing
options for any time of day ready to
blend smoothies savory harvest bowls
soups and more each single serving cups
takes one step to prepare just add water
milk twist or to a smoothie or heat up a
harvest bowl all of daily harvest
ingredients are carefully sourced for
maximum nourishment and flavor
go - daily - harvest for daily - harvest
calm and enter promo code toast to get
three free cups in your three cups free
in your first box that's promo code
toast at daily - harvest calm for three
free daily harvest cups again that's
daily - harvest com use code toast I
truly love daily harvest I love their
bowls and you know who loves their bowls
names are they gonna save me I'm like
you just said that
no does he loves them he really does so
perfect for him a man on the go
yeah and then I can pretend like I made
it like sweetie you forgot your
breakfast
you're still mrs. Doubtfire I am okay
are you ready to talk
Roni yeah it was such a great episode I
mean oh sorry Theo I got him all excited
okay it was like the longest weekend
ever in upstate and I really this is
really nice I know I was really starting
to see what the ladies are feeling when
it comes to LuAnn it's like everything
is about her even a night out that she
planned when they don't want to go to
this cabaret show what ends up being
money can't buy you class all about
cabaret all about the countess in like
it's been it's annoying and I'm a LuAnn
Stan I'm Malou Stan yeah it's annoying
um she really has found a way to make
everything about herself when she was
saying I haven't been back to Drew
since the Berkshires you can make that
argument about everything I haven't been
on this block I haven't been to this
restaurant since I watched rehab yeah
like no and she wasn't hearing anything
the ladies were saying when they were
arguing with her on her couch and that's
what's so frustrating she's like a Lisa
Vanderpump type yeah like people around
you are making a lot of sense and you
just can't be bothered towards the end
she got to a better place Bethany was
being so funny and her interviews yeah
it was a
I was thinking like a prime Bethenny
episode all around yeah al Fitz story
line interface relationship white outfit
she showed up to upstate in like the
white fur coat was so well yeah I could
have done without the Hat but I'm not a
hat girl me neither I'm not mrs. hat I'm
coming the Italian campaign unless
you're a marquee with the UH with the
lost kings that say the night King I was
like I could've been got them confused
when I told him we were going to Marquis
to see the lost kings he thought we were
going to see we the kings and he was
like check is Juliet is my favorite song
and sad he was like Larry playing and
getting ready and like I didn't have the
heart to tell him so he was like why
would they play it I'm like I don't know
Juliet such a good song I guess Juliet
Bart
are you with me okay so when they I was
surprised that LuAnn let the women off I
thought they were gonna all end up going
to margarita no you I thought that's
what it looks like in the preview
because Tinsley was there and he thought
Tinsley would be with the og crew I just
want to say Tinsley
was being primed Tinsley won because she
didn't mention Scott she didn't mention
baby she didn't mention her eggs or her
mom yeah and to because she was really
being like this snobby snarky mother and
girl that she isn't like we don't have
that character on the show she's like I
can't imagine living up here and not
being allowed to drink no told she was
being hilarious she was bringing the
person we thought we were getting when
we brought her on the show yeah like a
little holier than thou but like I
totally understand anyone from a New
York housewives I thinking you're better
than upstate and there's something about
upstate New York that's like really
polarizing because it's like like I love
upstate New York as I went to school
there you would probably be like what do
I pack for the state and like when I
took Zach there like he didn't fully
understand what I needed him to
understand cuz like when you're from the
south you just of like different you
have like different vistas and like you
have a different sense of like what the
country right he's more like a lake
house and you're more like upstate house
right so I totally understood how she
like wasn't getting the by but some of
the women were like so down for the vibe
yeah and the vibe really shifted when
Ramona came and she was like she came in
strong like a bull in a china shop with
all of her
centerpieces and I wasn't expecting to
really like love her as much as I did
this episode it was a really special
moment and I got exactly what Bethenny's
saying like I knew that Ramona grew up
in an abused house but I only knew that
because she's always using it as a line
of defense as an excuse for really poor
behavior she's always mentioning it at
the worst time right so it's like - like
you're all out of a hole
you forget that what she's saying is
horrible and you don't feel bad for her
but then she's like in this moment she's
like this is the table like it's such a
small town it totally was the table like
and she's like right across the street
and I totally like was feeling her and I
loved that Bethenny was feeling the
moment too and like really got you know
really that did her and listened to her
and shared and I never realized they are
two women who have single daughters and
they're single moms and they grew up
with abusive homes like it was this like
connectivity kind of moment it really
was and like I really wanted to take
LuAnn out when she sat down and said her
even have a breakdown - Ramona because
like Ramona was like sharing like she
did with others show he was so mean and
that's the thing about Ramona it's like
she's on the one hand like a bowl of on
but then on the other hand like if
someone had said that to me I wouldn't
have spoke I would have been mad at
would have ruined my night but she was
able like because that's something that
she would say to someone like in a you
know cuz she doesn't think before she
speaks sort of way she didn't take it
personally and like I kind of like how
okay if we Ramona's gonna be one way she
can also accept it on the other end you
should she can dish it and she can take
it right because that would have just
set like set me off yeah that could have
been a fight and it wasn't I know I
thought the same thing it was really
rude it was really like Sonja's [ __ ]
hair oh my god Sonja's losing it and she
loses it next week for real and she
falls off the table in Miami and I like
I love Lucid Sonja and like I love what
she's not drinking cuz she really is so
clear and makes such great points but I
also love like messy Sonja no I like
drinking Sonja when she's like she's
gotten to a good place you don't touch
the Morgan letters letters she's gone to
a really good place with drinking I feel
until next week obviously also it was a
primed her into episode yeah you know my
thing with Dorinda is I totally
understand why she's hitting on Ramona
like what she did at Aaron Burr moan at
that angel ball was Unforgiven what were
Ronan's it to her was unforgivable but
now she's taking up the wrong moments to
like take it out with her she's like
don't give me that face Ramona I
literally didn't make a face like she
was just saying are you leaving now so
she's wrong I get why she's upset but
she's taking it up at the wrong moment
you know and like blowing up yeah
but I also feel like this is who Ramona
is we know she's social times we know
she's you know not the most tactful all
the time but like she's 62 years old
like stop trying to change her you know
accept her if she or her friend accept
her as she is unless she's making like
horrible comment like you know did
someone ask your kid at school about
your sex or like how smart cause
dentists have been he was on drugs right
like those statements are unforgivable
but as a person like we we know how she
is also I mean it was said that during
had to sit at the event alone but from
what I understand about this event it's
like a very cool very exclusive party
and it's cool that during they got to go
yeah it's yeah it's like it's being
invited to the ball but then being
ditched by the person that invited you
it would be like if someone had made me
to the Met Gala but then I had to be
there alone mm-hmm okay
ruff-ruff but like I'd rather be there
at all yeah you know and like drina's
New York society she can make friends
yeah the surprise that Dorinda didn't
know anyone else I'm sure she did like
I'm sure it's a bit of an exaggeration
yeah I can't believe that guy with the
hair that Barbara like made out with
literally had the hair that she had on
Halloween oh yeah oh he was like kind of
cute I was feeling it for Barbara but
like oh my god I'm but I just I don't
have build together I just don't think
it's gonna work out no I don't know if
this is like the one for her no and I
don't know if like this show is oh I
don't think so either
yeah she's not working out for me
because she actually came in really
strong and I enjoyed her but she's now
too loyal to Beth I mean to LuAnn and
it's not fun anymore because she just
talks in circles and tells LuAnn
everything she wants to hear which is
what she thinks she needs to do but it's
boring we have some breaking news coming
in that LuAnn is back in jail okay let
me go
LuAnn cuz like that would be crazy and I
don't want to say it if it's not true so
everyone just stay tuned and you can
listen to a message from our sponsor
Chad you orders reality TV star LuAnn de
Lesseps into custody hold on it's from
Fox 23 okay so it's local news but it is
reputable I quote the judge suddenly
wasn't taking her probation seriously
after a positive alcohol test and
failure to attend meetings ooh a judge
on Thursday morning ordered LuAnn de
Lesseps into custody for alleged
probation violations
the judge said de Lesseps isn't taking
her
raishin seriously after a positive
alcohol test and failure to attend
meetings the TV star pleaded guilty to
lesser charges last year after Palm
Beach arrested her on charges of
disorderly intoxication resisting arrest
and battery on a law enforcement officer
at the Colony Hotel on Christmas Eve
holy [ __ ] hold on I want to reach me
thank God they did their union already
did they yesterday yeah Wow imagine you
miss two reunions maybe maybe the
reunion let her to drink hold on I need
to post this on our Instagram do me a
second
oh wow okay you keep talking we're still
alive
I will keep talking it's bringing it
wasn't 11 make a wish I wish for a
wonderful week I'm with toasters not
everyone has the most amazing time and
that we all just get to connect on like
a super deep level also like this is a
waste of a wish but I wish for nice-ish
weather even though like you can't
predict it and you know it is what it is
and it rained all the time last time and
we had the best time I also wish you
know for world peace and justice for the
boys and justice for the girls and
everyone out there who is who is
currently being harmed this one's for
the girl that is also 11:11 I wish were
LuAnn I hope she can find her way back
to a peaceful Center ok nothing ok sorry
I just want to post that on our
Instagram breaking news any other Briony
stuff you want to talk about um no I
think I covered each character but the
girls going to Miami is getting me
really excited for this new show on ABC
that you spoke about last week Grand
Hotel we've got a sneak peak of the
pilot and it is so good it is so good
you guys and I just found out that Eva
Longoria it's like one of the executive
producers on it so like having Eva
Longoria back on ABC behind the scenes
is exactly what I need this is like my
desperate housewife like yearning I
think I think it's coming back to life
and we need a sexy summer drama and now
we have one ABC's sexy summer drama
Grand Hotel is your new guilty pleasure
a five-star hotel with five-star secrets
set along the gorgeous backdrop of Miami
Beach
Eva Longoria executive produces this
bold a provocative family drama drenched
in romance and mystery a young woman's
disappearance during a hurricane
unravels a slew of scandals and lies
it's like clue for television has an
all-star cast including Academy Award
nominee domaine Bashir and Rosalyn
Sanchez Grand Hotel check it out Monday
June 17th on ABC so you have some time
but we got to check out the pilot and
it's the toastiness drama on television
and it's definitely a sexy summer series
it's a sexy
series and you can't ask for anything
more than that no you actually can't ask
for anything more than Eva Longoria
being back on ABC
yeah it's after just re watching
Desperate Housewives it's exactly what
my summer needed just to get a little
bit more sexier oh great I could I could
go for a little more sexy this summer eh
okay we need to talk about southern
charm and Catherine's house and I just
can't believe that Miss LuAnn stuff is
happening right now like what about her
shows no I know Live Nation is gonna I'm
sure they have a clause whatever
yeah okay Katherine's house okay I just
want to say that outside of Soto's day I
want to say one thing about southern
charm
I have been waiting as a Katharine Stan
for years not only for justice for
Katharine which has come but they're
like justice against Whitney and what he
did to Katherine where's Four Seasons he
berated her he ruined her in Thomas's
eyes his mother's eyes etc and then
Craig finally said what was true which
is that I think Whitney's just mad
because that one I because she didn't
choose him and everyone looked at Craig
like he was crazy and in my heart and
soul I knew that it was true but it was
just skimmed over because Whitney's a
pretty sure on the show Stu was made to
seem like a conspiracy theory but
finally we have confirmation that that
is the case yeah no I what he did to her
not letting her tell anyone and then
telling him at the most inopportune
moments and like she's still trying like
doesn't know what to say or what to do
like okay now you're on my good side but
I just old me wants to say [ __ ] you no
I'm not really like he's on my good side
him and his mom like I'm not chill in my
book and I get that like because there
are executive producers of the show and
they're like these staple figures in
like Charleston social life we're
supposed to like just glaze over the
fact that they're like horrible people
and I'm not no I'm not there were a few
times I truly chuckled when Shep was
like mother yeah
the way like and nobody nobody addresses
like the weird elephant in the room like
that Whitney lives with his mom and like
where's he always go coming and going on
an airplane like he's so odd it's so I
but the show is so good and it's like
it's good even before they are adding
this Eliza character and she's a full
she's in the cast and I got to know a
little bit more about her and she's
definitely interesting she's definitely
interesting so she like fell from
society and I guess now her family will
allow her to be on a reality show which
like you know partly a fall from grace
truly a fall from grace which is
you're saying um but I don't know her
trying to compare like she's been
through stuff just like catherine has
there's a difference between like going
through something as a product of
someone else's you know miss steps as
opposed to like doing it on your own
like going through it on your own you
know yeah it's nuts in like and your
name still on a bridge and a sidewalk in
a bus in a building like you've never
got to worry about like putting a roof
over his head over fighting for custody
by your kids it's like so nothing's like
you're not invited to a party but like
no one took away your money like oh and
like your civil liberties like to see
your kids right like totally it's just
so not the same and by the way you don't
look like the kind of girl who wants to
be a debutante no not a job not to judge
a book by its cover but totally but
those extensions don't scream Debbie
don't she was saying like the downfalls
of like being kicked out of society
we're not being able to be a debutante I
was like okay this girl has never
experienced real hardship in her life
right I know I she's definitely now like
you know experiencing like I'm sure it's
hard and Camryn posted an Instagram like
saying please don't like be so mean to
lies I've known her forever but then it
was also weird because so she's clearly
like a lot younger than everyone else
and then eight ranges on this show are
just interesting - yeah like Thomas was
50 and Kathryn was 21 and Patricia's 19
but it's like weird that Cameron is now
on a show with someone who like her
husband used to babysit like it's almost
too like it was too big yeah yeah I
agree
she's giving me like Raquel vibes where
it's like it is too late for new people
here no I agree and the group is
established enough and they have their
own drama that we didn't need another
character I think it's weird that they
brought someone on especially someone
that is like coming for Kathryn and it's
annoying
yeah I think it's an unnecessary
addition and I'm really not here for it
but she does make it to a full cast
member because she's in the cast photos
money so um I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt because Cameron has
asked me to and I'm loving Cameron and I
didn't even wear my dog is beautiful how
much I missed her last season she barely
filmed me because she was pregnant her
home is beautiful and we've seen that
dock before but I never realized that it
was her house
yeah no it's stunning like she is living
the life of Riley and I love how she
goes to Chelsea's and it's like this
makes me feel like a grandma she's
living the life of Riley because she has
like this huge like life outside the
show and nobody precious heard like get
her husband and I film in her house like
there's so many parts of her life that
are hidden from the show and like nobody
pressures or like in better prompt
like you bleed out or you die right but
it's like she is interesting enough on
her own and good for her and like I
think that's why it's not a huge deal to
me that Lila won't feel much like if you
keep being interesting you that is a
like a privilege that you get to keep I
have to say I do think that Chelsea
might be my favorite person on reality
television ever I know I think she's so
beautiful she's an incredible girl she's
so cool
like she's she just is cool do you know
what I mean like she's the girl like you
know like there are girls who are like I
can't hang out with girls like I like to
drink beer and they do it in like an
annoying way like she's like actually
that girl and it's not me she's like
their role model and they're not
achieving Chelsea status no but she's
beautiful and she's just so cool and I
love her I love her I love all the women
on the show and I love the friendship
that they have in like it really all
came about like through the show like
Naomi and Danny and Catherine and cam
and like they're all getting along and
it's like they are so secure and like
wonderful as women and not only are the
men not but they make the men look even
worse and I I'm loving Madison Austin's
girlfriend like giving the boys a taste
of their own medicine
Shep is so wrong he's miss me I love him
but he's so wrong and there must be more
to the story but why don't they keep
showing that same two seconds from the
clip but give us something more give us
more I mean that whole thing is so crazy
I'm like what Madison data is not nearly
as bad as what Austin did not at all I'm
like even next week that she's sliding
into other people's teams like that's
something all these guys would do but
she's giving them a taste of their own
medicine
and I am here for her I've been here for
the women of southern charm me to Naomi
and her little business is so [ __ ]
cute oh my god I love her she's just
like out here progressing yeah in her
life she is and like a prime example
last season Naomi was in school I think
she wasn't running her business yet and
Austin also was to start trying to start
up a beer company a year later look
where the nation's business is up and
running and Austin's beer company is on
and like honestly I don't wanna like
make him feel bad about it but what a
missed opportunity big I wouldn't he
can't set it I thought it was the most
brilliant idea ever because not only
like we don't have a Bravo beer yeah and
he's a beer expert he would go to these
restaurants and like just
know more about beer than anyone like he
did it for his job he used to like sell
beer like commercially he won't work for
another beer company and he's so
knowledgeable I'm here like if I were to
drink a beer I want to drink what he
says his best it's so funny how like the
storyline of the show has now evolved
into like everyone working on their
Bravo created business you know what he
means yeah but like some people are
doing it better than others I think chef
gear makes like a ton of money yeah he
Shep like everything he touches turns to
go guy he's very lovable and he has that
going for him Craig getting an assistant
great for him he needs it it's not an
assistant it's like a mom
yeah it's like a life coach I like a
live in like a babysitter yeah a
babysitter yes babysitter um and I hope
that this season Austin like works on
the beer so that by the end it launches
because if this season comes and goes
without some without him telling us
where we could buy his beer it'll be
annoying I'll be really upset for him
because I mean Austin Jackie will be the
face of your beer because she's like
really [ __ ] about [ __ ] about I've
never had a whole beer in my life but if
Austin's beer comes to fruition I will
drink an entire one on this show okay I
think that's fair okay so we are going
to take a quick break and bring out
Layla or who is a contestant on Project
Runway if you have any questions project
warming related or for Laila herself
feel free to drop it in the YouTube
stream but we will be back in a couple
minutes so stay tuned
you
we are back with Lila or Project Runway
start but more importantly toaster
welcome to the show thank you for having
did you love having toaster as we do on
the show I'm so excited and out there
just spreading the gospel of chesty
about its horror and you've been a
toaster for a while forever
for like way back you're just born a
toaster I really when you went on the
show like you missed some episode so
were you able to listen to podcasts [ __ ]
episodes when did you guys film we
filmed in the fall and we wrapped in the
winter and the first thing I did
whenever we finished wrapping I was like
I need to laugh I need to see these
girls I need to catch up with what's
going on in the world so thank you for
catching her to speed toasties q did you
wear this maybe did you create this
outfit so it's a combination
I made these pants I love them and then
this is Veni at tan from Project Runway
I'm wearing his job any two he's also
from Dallas - Dallas designers so Dallas
and Dallas did you make any lifelong
friends or enemies in the house friends
for sure um
Tessa Clarke is one of my really good
friends we were roommates yeah that
brings me actually to my first question
which is a very couple of question we
got from the taster I saw yes I don't
know how to delicately ask this s-says
arey but did test get a bed edit or is
this really her so I can't really speak
too much on editing but what I will say
is she's a wonderful person like she's
so much fun she's such a cool girl and I
think they showed a lot of moments of
like her having fun with fish me they
were really good friends and she's just
yeah she's a great girl so I don't know
I mean I know people are seeing certain
things and she's hearing certain things
but she's great and I love her and I've
been to Cincinnati already to do it a
pop-up shop with her and yeah i don't
know i mean so edit wise i don't know
but she's she's really cool okay that's
good to know
yes you yeah was there anything like
off-camera drama in the house like
people who really didn't get along no
that's the thing is like i was talking
to people from other seasons and like
did you guys get along like we got along
so great and i feel like you see it on
camera like there really wasn't drama
when we had drama like you saw it like
it was just like I don't know like they
did a really good job casting and like
fitting us all together because we mesh
so well yeah well speaking of casting
how did you get
show what was the process like because
like it really as far as reality shows
like it's probably the most talented
group like the people who go on the toe
are unbelievably talented so how do you
like how do you even get there so it was
um it was kind of a quite a process was
throughout this summer I I was a big fan
of the show
like I knew I wanted to get on I had a
friend that kind of convinced me to
actually be on the show because I was
like I don't think I'm a reality person
I'm pretty chill I'm like a very mellow
person I'm not like a TV person I
thought and she was like why don't you
let casting producers decide yeah and
then you'll figure it out so I over the
summer I set in an application I heard
back it was a lot of back-and-forth
travelling things like that showing up
with my clothes and showing everybody
what I could make and um yeah and then I
got the call and I went straight there
and started filming that's so exciting
how do you watch prior seasons in the
past so yeah I was like studying it yeah
I was like taking notes like okay this
is what you should do for this challenge
I think I can expect this kind of
challenge by this point in time right
yeah this is what I can do to not like
get off first because oh my god you know
under the radar for like that very nice
I might stay like he no more chill but I
mean I brought my best game like I
brought you did I best work
I stayed safe for a while I was on top
for a while and then I had one look that
I wasn't really proud of and it was
menswear and I don't do menswear and I
don't do costumes and then I was out
okay do you think like the challenges
are always so challenging but do you
think it's gotten like hard like they
keep on raising the bar so when you
watch a cold episodes are you like
that's so unfair right what they got to
do versus what we had to do I've seen
some really cool episodes where I'm like
they went to a hardware store and a
floral store and that was their
unconventional they'd say and that was
so cool they had like the most crazy
Couture floral pieces and that's very
neat too um and for are unconventional
we were out camping oh my god cold
wilderness so hard on Staten Island I'm
not a cold weather girl but honestly it
still inspires you to create amazing
things and I love what I created in that
element
so me as being a fan I loved old like
challenges and stuff but our season I
feel like we really brought it we had
some crazy challenges yeah yeah so I
mean I feel like pretty proud about this
was a question we got from Momo and cat
they would love to know more about your
zero waste philosophy and how you
implement that like in your clothing in
your business yeah so zero waste
basically means that I don't throw
anything out I pattern with zero waste
in mine so whenever I pattern I powder
them like puzzle pieces and nothing is
thrown out everything is kind of cut to
use and whatever is left over is
reimplemented back into the collection
so that's in the form of like accessory
and did you do that on Project Runway -
I try to do it as much as I could I was
minimal waste on pressure anyway so like
and you can kind of see it like I'll
have like a tiny scrap pile and then
everything that was left over I would
gather up and then recycle so I have a
cleanest area always and I was always
like funding I think but it does take
longer so I was like trying to explain
that you know it does take longer it's a
longer process but it's so worth it in
the end and I feel like it pushes you to
be more creative in that kind of sphere
yeah well we were just talking about how
Prada has decided to not use oh yeah fur
anymore so like right that amazing
that's a big win cruelty free because we
love animals do like you want to you
want to come for him I'll twirl for you
okay totally oh this is a good question
is there music plagued during the
fashion shows or can you hear the
commentary from the judges I can't yeah
you can't hear because there's they're
far away anyway there's some distance
there uh-huh
so there's music playing like you hear
and talk about anything but yeah I mean
basically um I don't know what they're
saying and you kind of have to just like
guess or whenever you're out there and
you're top over your bottom you hear the
feedback which is so helpful so I was
really interested when I started
watching this season because in the past
few seasons whether it was on Brava or
live time they were evolving in their
models yeah and I would love to hear
what the like who do you design for and
did you find it challenging when they
were moving around the different types
of models mmm no I thought it was
actually really cool I kind of expected
that because they've worked with models
of different sizes for years um I think
since like season 14 or something like
that
so I kind of expected that and I was
really looking forward to that because
I'm I do a lot of custom wear and so I
have clients of all sizes that's the
real world that you're not just
designing for your dress form pretty
much like and you're really limited and
like
it's kind of sad you know like as
professional designers we should be
designing for women of all sizes no I
couldn't agree I mean you get used to
working with certain models because like
you know how to like just kind of talk
to each other and you communicate really
well but it was fun to mix it up I have
read me a lot like that was my problem
with Frankie who was like the first two
weeks she was there just talking about
how she designs for plus-sized women in
both times she got a plus-size model and
like couldn't even stitch two things
together this really was not the show
for her and that's where like she lost
me how was Carly o'clock that's what I
was just gonna say Carly oh my god I
love Carly she's the best I I don't know
if she liked was mutable I know she
likes you as a person we get along great
um but Carly was amazing she was a
really quick she was great to have as a
judge she was a really good host I mean
yeah it's a totally new Project Runway
it's on back on Bravo Christian was our
mentor he's insanely countess and
amazingly that like so cool working with
him oh my god yes and he designs for
Leslie Jones a lot love her yeah so
she's amazing yeah he's so talented he
was great he had a lot of good advice
and I felt like I really meshed well
with you yeah I got my aesthetic in my
vibe so it must be like really helpful
talking someone who's been in the
position yeah what you guys have to go
through is really like so challenging
mentally like artistically etc so like
he can really provide oh god yeah he's
amazing hi precious
so yeah he was 21 I want to say wow are
you crazy your early 20s right at 40
yeah younger than me he was like yeah he
was like younger than all of us yeah
there's one so that's so impressive I
think he came right out of school and
then when I'm proud you're away and then
one it's well having his feedback as
he's been in the industry dressing
people for red carpet stressing people
for like everything for years and years
now it's like really on point and he
knows like what's trending what to say
where we want to go as young designers
so he was great are there like crazy
rules like on The Bachelor you're not
allowed to have a phone you know how to
read you can't work out yeah did you
have downtime what do you like to do
during the downtime um it's like that's
all work really is like it's fashion
boot camp so your phone no
sucks but then like you're in New York
City can't you just like Oh reality yeah
yeah but yeah I mean it was you're like
I think they just I really want you like
immersed in the experience like you're
in it you're doing it like you and I
feel like my work was even better
because of that like there's no
distraction yeah working you're with the
do group of designers I'm with 15 other
super talented people and it was really
incredible
this is such a good question from Amanda
I'd sin' from a fellow wannabe designer
is there any cheating involved when
creating a garment the contestants are
giving great are given so little time to
construct a garment there's no way that
it can all be sewn are the contestants
allowed to cheat with hot glue I mean
they provide all the tools for you
except for like you know we bring some
of our own things from home if we want
but yeah I mean like they have hot glue
gun it's a clear cheating I don't know
is it I mean when we're camping like you
saw has hot gluing because we had to
like it was like it was unconventional
material so your hot gluing like rope on
to like tarp so yeah like of course here
you have to hot glue
sometimes you have to but like for me as
a designer I don't know hot glue and my
practice backgrounds I'm trying to say
it's true to myself as I can so for me
no I didn't really hot glue a lot except
for camping and then all the items that
you made where are they now
so I have no idea you don't have that
[ __ ] it's a good question that's so
interesting to make a Project Runway
zeusian questions I just want to know
like the logistics behind it I think
like I think that giving person for a
project from a to come on the show so
we're getting our charts I have you know
Joe no I have to meet him yeah birdie
such injustice on that show but someone
and that stress was so cute and at least
it should like a style vision style oh
yeah I can so Janelle Monae or Miley
Cyrus
yeah that was really upset that was a
worship setting but is she face thing
about Cavanaugh getting eliminated week
one it was not upset about it I mean I
do think out of the two bottom two like
hers was less bad because Frankie like
she had an unfinished garment like she
literally couldn't make her job was
whether ugly or beautiful to make a
garment and she didn't do that like
baseline
yes Cavanaugh's looks like from forever
21 it's clearance rack but it still was
a garment that was sewn together so they
both snug and they both shouldn't have
been there but the Kavanagh should have
gone home the second week and Frankie
got home the first week okay but when
Frankie was at the bottom again the
second week I'm like this [ __ ] are you
kidding me
yeah I feel like being on the bottom
twice in a row it's like okay yeah maybe
this isn't your thing maybe there's a
different kind of platform for you yeah
you know well down to six now
yes we're down to six and do you know
who wins
we won't make you say but you know is
the Project Runway family like The
Bachelor family like they all hang out
after every contestant from every season
like do you guys have that sort of like
camaraderie in the Project Runway world
we do whatever they do yeah like it's
crazy because I think like you know you
don't know what it's gonna be like I
went in there thinking it was gonna be
fierce competition it was gonna be super
cutthroat and it is a competition but
when you're helping each other out and
you're all working alongside together
and I'm like for me I'm staying in my
own lane like I am eco luxury I'm zero
waste like no one else there does that
so I'm doing my own thing I felt like I
was really trying to like better myself
each week within the competition and
everyone kind of said that we were not
like look at throw like undercut people
said you're gonna attitude you really do
so overall what was the experience like
what do you feel like you learned I feel
like I have it was meanest fashion boot
camp so I'm a much faster designer I've
learned to really go with my gut I think
you can kind of see in my episode 9
where I was eliminated I kind of like
got in my head a lot and I've learned to
like not be such an echo chamber and to
just kind of like go with your initial
guide I have a business partner at home
so I work with the team and that helps a
lot to you but yeah just like really go
for it trust yourself and your intuition
and stay zero waste just well Congrats
I'll meet you at nine weeks because
that's [ __ ] hard yeah and it's thanks
for being a toaster because you make us
look cool I love being a toaster
everyone's on Instagram keep up with
with all your designs where can people
follow you you can follow me on my purse
Instagram it's Lila Christiana or you
can follow fara official we have our
website ferret calm and fair official on
Instagram
very cool well I want to have something
made for myself like maybe a jumpsuit
yeah custom because yeah I'm a custom
egos like sure you got summer um thank
you for being here thank you twisters
for tuning in if your company cam toast
this weekend we'll see you tomorrow at
five o'clock we're so excited to see you
if you're not coming be sure to keep up
with hashtag camp toast or follow the
morning show us on Instagram as we will
be documenting the entire thing have an
amazing weekend otherwise this is the
last episode of the week and we will see
you on Tuesday happy Memorial Day make
memories
you